will crow on the mound for the pirates
tonight making his seventh appearance
his sixth start in a pirates uniform his
best start this year came against the
cubs back on may eighth he went six
innings and allowed two runs jack
peterson did all that damage last night
as the leadoff hitter back in there
tonight in a pop-up
bunch of guys going to converge
[Applause]
and it was
newman who's yelling i got it i got it i
got it peterson is gone and here comes
chris bryant let's go off the end of the
bat
alanko
bryant retired two down nobody on the
batter is javier baya
by his lines a base hit on the center
field on the airbaya is a two out single
kind of a soft line drive
first hit of the game and the battery's
ian half half takes low and inside ball
four a lot of deep counts in the first
inning dubs have a single and a walk two
outs two on for wilson contreras three
two that's in there with a fastball
right on the inner edge as the cubs will
strand two trevor williams former pirate
makes his tenth cubby start see the
numbers aren't all that great for him
era just a tick under six
first one to frazier
that one in the air that baez will catch
one pitch one out for trevor williams
now facing ben gamel lying to right
field
and sails over the head of peterson and
camel not gonna stop it's a trip trip
triple for gavel it always seems to
happen you put a guy in a new position
in the first is never an easy one gamble
the third one down no score bottom of
the first and the batter now is brian
reynolds and he hits a high pop fly this
is not going to drive in the run bodhi
on the left side of the infield the
third baseman makes the catch that's as
good as a strikeout two down two outs
jacob stallings ready to step in he's
bounced to third glove by bodhi on the
backhand long toss across good throw to
chris bryant and that ends the inning
crow has had a hard time throwing
strikes lead off walk that'll do and
with ortega on it'll bring up
david body but i've always said if
you're going to nibble you have to
commit to it the guy who really gets
hammered is the nibble nibble nibble now
i'm going to give in and throw you that
cookie right david bode waits it's a
high drive in the center field that ball
is deep back toward the center field
wall it's gone for a home run david
boney puts a charge into one a two run
homer and the cubs jump out front 2-0
eric sogar gets a single still nobody
out in the inning trevor williams his
assignment now is to try to lay down a
bun that one lays through the right side
base head there's your bunt says trevor
williams third hit of the year and two
aboard dad loves it yeah marked that in
the scorebook dad and nobody out and
jack peterson peterson swings and hits
it high and deep into center but
playable reynolds is shy of the track
makes the catch soul guard's going to
tag and head to third
and he'll get in there
so of all people jack peterson makes the
first out of the inning minute first and
third with one away in the second inning
cubs lead by two and here's chris bryant
with an rbi opportunity that ball is
lined and a base head out into center
field in the score is so guard chris
bryant an rbi single and it is three to
nothing that's gonna be it yeah
he's getting him out of the game he's
thrown almost 50 pitches and ending in a
third wow that's not a happy pirate
manager right there dwayne underwood jr
is coming on there's craig with a nice
play and
unfortunately underwood apparently
didn't get over to the bag in time for
newman to throw over there underwood
upset with himself pounded his fist
remember williams ends up at third baez
at first here's ian happ batting 2-0
swung on hit high and deep to right
and polanco shy of the track waiting on
it he'll make the catch at the end
against underwood does a nice job autumn
of ending number two gregory polanco
first up
and a cold strike three got him was that
a change-up it was a change-up and
trevor williams strikes out gregory
polanco one away swing and a miss nice
pitch to seymour running in back-to-back
strikeouts cubs lead the pirates three
to nothing wilson contreras will lead it
off and he swings and chops one over the
third baseman deep in the hole the short
kevin newman throws onto first got him
what a play by kevin newman that's not
derek jeter that is kevin newman with
another spectacular play trevor williams
has been sensational give it up one hit
that's the only base runner he's retired
11 in a row swing and a miss struck him
out that's number six polanco's gone
he's an ultra predator mode here tonight
he's he's feeling it he's attacking
these hitters
in the year to left
at a seven pitch inning the pirates go
in order
for the fourth straight time sogard
cruises into second and eric has a
double trevor williams due up oh baby
out of the center field
stop talking about pitchers can't hit
boog he's got a two-hit game oh my
goodness dad's got to be just going
bananas in the stands tonight with what
trevor is doing on the mound and in the
batter's box first and third with two
outs it's up to chris bryant hit hard
fair ball based it into right sogard
into score for chris bryant his second
ribby single of the night and it's four
nothing
trevor williams still on the mound five
shutout innings pirates have a man at
second base and a pinch hitter coming up
for the buckos it's eric gonzalez
bounced into right field a base hit
runner wave the boxer on the board
eric gonzalez
who's first at bat of the night makes it
4-1 third time through the order yep
it's been an issue for trevor it's an
issue for just about every pitcher in
the game here's a fastball ground ball
to first glove by bryant goes to second
one fires back to first for a double
play wow that is nicely done three six
three and they turn the double play and
that is exactly what trevor williams
needed swinging a miss strike three
williams strikes out gamble and the
inning comes to an end craig kimbrell
earned his tenth save of the year last
night and gamma will lead
[Music]
[Applause]
deep to off
off the glove of half ben camel into
second base with a lead off double ryan
reynolds at the plate swag and a miss
and he got him
reynolds is gone and that is out number
one jacob stallings the batter with a
man at second and one down in the year
left field ortega
and the cubs
and out away from the w
it's all up to polanco oh
it almost looks like he said i i would
like the runner to go to third base he's
bothering me at second he may have just
done that a purpose that's sort of
that's the point yeah and because the
issue they had with the signs and
drilling contrasts with the 99
mile-an-hour fastball the other day
kimball deal
got him ball game cubs win and the cubs
are red hot a half game out of first